i see you on the racetrack let's go like
for real pharrell let's do it all right
now it is time to graze in the southwest
area here where there's a new
plant-powered restaurant feeding
families the all-natural way so thanks
to cisco for sponsoring this segment we
are now being introduced to co-owners
and chefs john simmons and amelia cooper
of gray's kitchen welcome to the show
guys thanks for having us it's so funny
because i met amelia actually at an
event earlier this week and we had no
idea that we'd be meeting again here
you're making me natural sugar scrubs so
you're all things natural yes
and grains catered it right which that
yeah
so i've already tasted the food okay
all right so let's talk about just the
inspiration behind grades and why you
guys brought it to the community i mean
it was kind of inspiration i mean it's
kind of like um interesting story
uh the kovid yeah took down her business
she does she has a hair and makeup
business so all the events were canceled
in the meantime my wife who's vegan
got a sample of some of her food she was
doing some like meal prep out of her
house for a small group of friends and
we just fell in love with her food and
then we fell in love with her and then
the next thing you know
bam we got a business
that is incredible we love you
we love a resilient story coming out of
kobe so amelia let's talk about the food
i've already
grown to love since i've met you earlier
this week so what do you guys have on
the menu so i'm going to start with
what's right in front of you because we
think it's going to be one of our heroes
you are looking at korean barbecue
nachos now everything we make is whole
food plant-based we really don't use a
lot of faux products so you've got some
cashew cheese you've got some gucci
aioli you've got soy curls which is a
whole food product with some yummy
barbecue korean barbecue in there
and some chilies so right oh my goodness
right right but those soy curls are
crazy because it's just like s
soy protein yeah but it soaks up
whatever flavor that you put into it
nothing is
in that in that artificial dish is
artificial it's all plant-based that is
incredible no wonder you are predicting
this will be your hero i'm hoping i
think so because we're big fans of it in
fact i'm pretty sure that the soya curls
is what won me over there i'm pretty
sure it was the soy carrot got you and i
say predicting because you guys are
opening next week yes yes you guys have
to get in there and you know try it
firsthand yeah what about these items
over here so um we know we've got
football season coming up so we want to
make sure we had some hearty dishes on
the menu
get you steady for all your beer
drinking we have some awesome vegan
chili with a corn cake dumpling oh my
god so it's caramelized on the outside
and pudding like on the inside it's
perfect with that chili it's good on a
cold day okay and no i know we only have
a couple seconds left so even though the
food looks amazing i want to taste it
all let's talk about the drinks because
this is something unique you guys have
on the menu too so we've got
booze we got wine we got the boots we
got them
we got the boots everybody if you've
never had a kombucha cocktail so we're
gonna make our own like crazy cocktails
like vodka sodas with all kinds of
different little
spritzers and and herbs and fruits and
stuff infused vodkas
craft beer vegan wine we got it all okay
perfect you've got it all so you guys
have to check them out next week and
opening thank you to cisco for
sponsoring the second check out check
out gray's on south buffalo call them at
725-204-5128 or visit gracekitchen.com
thank you guys cheers cheers cheers
craft the boots it looks so good save me
some rocky